the jurgen experience i don't know if i
told you the story but um well actually
like my my wife was lost one time
that's actually um
and uh
i actually didn't think that i was gonna
find her alive
so that that was actually probably one
of the worst outdoor experiences that
ended up turning out good save your life
but um it wasn't for my own sake how you
met her
no it wasn't how i met her so you'd
already met her and then yeah i'd met
her we dated
um like she was a little she's younger
than me and
like i'm traveling she had moved
away and we just kind of like went apart
and we were gonna get back together uh
this was like a couple years after so we
were no we were not actually dating at
the time
um
but i i was on a trip in alaska i just
got back and then her sister
called me it was like
danielle's missing
and
we uh and
like you know one of those like nobody
can find her and like maybe i have the
skill set to go help out in some way
and so i like literally
i just i was unpacking all this i was
doing a film thing in alaska i just got
in
maybe five minutes into my house i just
left all my [ __ ] i called my brother and
my friend and was like danielle's
missing we're gonna go
so we we gathered up our stuff and uh
drove she was in central nevada
she was visiting her dad and like just
um
gone out on a trail and never came back
and so it was like
it's like the high desert
mid
mid summer
so it's you know like
pretty hot in the daytime really cold at
night really high elevation kind of
thing
and i think she'd been missing for this
would be going on her third day oh [ __ ]
yeah and um
so
i was like oh [ __ ] and there was a so we
got there
and there had been like a facebook group
and they they had the blackhawk
helicopters out looking couldn't find
her search and rescue they did the dog
thing everything
and uh so i got there it was like
probably 5 p.m still daylight when i got
there
and uh
we get we get there and
kind of talk to
the search and rescue and i'm like there
one of the guys kind of recognized me
and knew i wasn't what i did and i had
my whole pack like i was ready to glass
like we were going to just normally on
search and rescue things like they want
people out of the area but they knew
that i knew what i was doing so they let
us in to help and
so
kind of met with them talked to them
there's a facebook group thing of
like what they'd seen and there was this
report of a vehicle with like mexico
plates leaving the area
and i don't know like why how you know
you start like people start
saying like okay i saw her last wearing
this so she the last she'd been seen she
was just wearing like running stuff
uh didn't have any equipment with her
she had gone up and then the search and
rescue dogs like they went up the canyon
and then they came back and they did
that multiple times so the theory was
like she went up
came back and then people they were
actually kind of thought since they put
in a search effort that she was gone
like taken
so you know that that kind of shits in
your mind too right right so you're like
okay because they saw a mexico place
yeah and i'm like i don't know why
you know why that would but kidnapping
yeah something right right because they
had the
you know they were working under the
assumption that she wasn't there like
out there right so you know they kind of
asked like
did you like a little interview like you
know how far do you think she going i
was like well she trains for marathons
like she could be 20 miles from this
point we don't really know
you know um we don't know what happened
either like she could have fallen broke
like we just don't know what happened
um so they showed us where the the dogs
were
had gone and where they inspected and
everything
and i
i thought
i was like you know my initial like the
way that i think was like well whatever
you guys have done
didn't work right
so i'm just going to kind of take the
things that you've said and just and
look at it through a lens of like that
didn't work so i got we've got to just
try something different so i loaded up
my pack and i had like all my optics
everything and i was just like i my
thought was i'm just going to go out
there and and part of it too was kind of
like a wreck in some ways like i'm not
just going to sit around and do nothing
right so it's starting to get dark at
this point
and my thought was like i'm not coming
back until i find something so i just
load up my pack like i'm going on a back
country hunt with all my [ __ ] and just
go aft go back there and see what i can
do and i wanted to be
it was good in night time so i wanted to
be like ready first thing in the morning
thinking when that before that light
gets harsh and she's in the shade like
if you're trying to survive in the
desert when it's it's super cold at
night so you're probably moving around
to stay warm and then in the morning
you'd probably still be moving around
but once it gets daytime then you're
probably
in the heat and you're in the shade so
uh there was
the guy so they had blackhawk and
it had to go back because it timed out
like it needed fuel they're there at
that point and they were searching in
the middle of the day which i thought
you know be better to search in the
evening after the heat on the rocks
cools off a little bit you can use a
flare system like thermals
because everything in the desert cools
down so fast that you might be able to
find her at night using a thermal system
so i asked the guy if we could get a
thermal fleer system and so they were
working on getting something
and so i had one of the guys take me
into the
back i just said like drive me as far
they had like these little ranger things
in the whole their uh you know like
off-road vehicle like uh
what polaris yeah yeah
or can-am or whatever so uh i was like
just driving as far back as you can so
you drive me back and now it's starting
to get dark and i had a big flashlight
and
i just like looked at it and before it
got dark and just looking around it's
like oh i'd probably go up here no trail
i was like man we've hiked all over the
world together no trails we never go on
trails
so i just thought i'd start going here
and now but at this point it's dark and
i just started hiking in the dark up
this canyon
and it's probably
uh
maybe
probably close to midnight at this point
and i was thinking about
you know like a lot of shit's going
through my head thinking man what's it
going to be like if i find her dead
and
okay like am i prepared for this or what
if i and the thing that really like
messed me up was what if i never find
her
like i just couldn't and these things
like kept going through my head and i'm
literally
in the dark like and there's no moon at
all just hiking in the dark i like just
stopped and you just i like i felt very
very very helpless and i'm like
literally praying for a sign of some
kind
and i look down and there's this weird
scuff mark
and i'm like
i just keyed in on it
in
randomly walking in the dark and there's
deer tracks everywhere and i just
started like following this one track
and it just didn't look right but it's
not like the kind of ground where you
can see tracks you know i inspected it i
didn't see shoes and i get up to this
like flat bench area and i just have
this weird feeling and i'm like yeah and
then i saw a light on the top of the
mountain so i thought oh man maybe
that's somebody had come in hiked in
with like
thermals and i can use that
to then look for her and i'll come back
to this area
so i um i call my brother and my buddy
on the radio i'm like hey you know
i'm up here and they were around they
were looking around the rocks where the
dogs had turned around thinking maybe
she went up there fell into something
and got stuck in like places people
normal search and rescue wasn't gonna
look so they were looking in kind of
those areas
so i hike up to where the light was on
the hill and it happened to just be like
people that were in the area like a
couple that were just like
whatever camping
and
you know i was like hey you know i
talked to him i was like hey here's a
picture have you seen this person no we
haven't seen anything i was like cool
you know like the area's kind of closed
down right now just so you know because
they're looking for like cool keep an
eye out
and so
now i'm away from that spot i just like
i started to think about it and i like i
called my brother and buddy and they're
like yeah you know we don't see anything
around here like maybe we'll we'll start
first thing in the morning and i was
like okay you know i'm going to stay up
here and i'm going to go back to the
spot i'm just going to camp out up here
or whatever but i got to go check this
spot first so i walk back to that like
little
bench thing
and i sit down i turn off my light
and i just yell out i'm like hey
danielle this is remy if you can hear me
i'm not leaving till i find you
i'm just like sitting there and then i
hear remy
and i was like
oh [ __ ] it was so faint i was thinking
to myself did i just like
did i actually hear that so i had my
radio and i called my brother and a
friend and i was i said hey i just heard
her
i'm gonna turn my radio off in case
maybe that's like i'm only gonna hear
one more time i'm turn my radio off get
somebody up here
so and i just said that over the radio
because i don't want the radio going off
for some random reason well the next
time she said something or whatever so i
flipped the radio off
and i just started like moving in that
direction where i i heard something and
i yelled out again and didn't hear
anything and then kept moving and yelled
out again and
when i before it got dark i remember
like there's this big basin almost like
a
amphitheater kind of shape right and on
the top side was all these cliffs and
everything so i thought well maybe i
heard it across the canyon and she fell
into one of those cliffs so i'm like
moving in that direction but i'm trying
to move like
you know when you're chasing an elk and
it's like that you've gotta you've gotta
run but you can't run loud right you're
like that stalking running like trying
to be quiet because it was very very
faint and still i'm partially thinking
i'm going crazy
and uh
so i
um
i get up to that
uh i i keep going and i yell i'm like
danielle
can you hear me and then i hear grammy
or i i heard her uh yeah she actually
said my name again i was like and i
flipped on my light and she was like 300
yards below me
i was like oh [ __ ] so i i run to her
thinking like
oh look this is crazy so i run up to her
and she just was like so confused and
she's like i think she's she's like
hallucinating
and i was like are you okay she's like i
know and i was like um
i was like do you do you know who i am
she's like i think so
do you do you know you're like just you
know like basic first responder
questions right can you answer some
simple questions like do you know your
name like
no [ __ ] nor name like yeah like i don't
know uh
i don't know
and i'm like okay
and then so i call the um
i flipped my thing on i called my buddy
and i was like all right i found like
i've got her we need
paramedics here now
and uh so my buddy was they were
probably
two or three miles from the base camp my
buddy joe just like takes off it's just
like sprinting
down to the base camp
and then my brother is hiking up to me
to help her
and so um we tried to i we didn't have
service where we were and i lost i was i
have a satellite messenger but i left it
in the truck um so my buddy goes down
and i think somehow
somebody had called
whoever you know paramedics in the whole
deal
and
so my buddy joe this is the funny part
is my buddy joe runs down to the search
and rescue camp
and he's like remy founder we need to go
and one of the guys that was kind of in
charge was like an older guy he not the
guy that goes in the field or anything
just he's like you know somebody thought
they heard something but it could have
been a mountain lion so we're just gonna
save our energy for the morning search
and my buddy joe's like
he's like [ __ ] you i'm commandeering
your vehicle and he just takes the
ranger the razor thing and she rips off
toward town because you know
like to go meet get get something what a
[ __ ] yeah like i mean like who's ever
heard like we thought we heard something
but it could have been a mountain lion
like that doesn't even matter and you're
saying you have her right yeah he's like
he's just like he you know i mean
that's like a scene in a movie yeah
there's this one lazy cop yeah exactly
it was just like i was like this is this
is too crazy like when he told me that
story i couldn't i was just rolling
laughing and also concerned like why the
[ __ ] would you say it could have been a
mountain lion dick so
so uh they go up and we end up he he
gets meets up with them and they get up
to the top
they were able to like kind of get up
this ridge and then came down with a a
stretcher and my brother and i were able
to like you know do like a
help her get up the mouth did you give
her water did she yeah oh yeah so i gave
her water i think i'm like here drink
this and like she like as soon as it hit
her lips she like spit it out she's like
fire like
so she was so dehydrated so dehydrated
like it just started like burning like
the water was burning oh my god um
yeah
yeah and so um we got her we got her up
to the paramedics and then obviously to
the hospital and like a pretty extensive
rehydration
uh thing and
yeah and you know like she she wasn't
feeling good when she went out and i
think it was just like oh i'm gonna go
you when you're sick or whatever you're
just like
not feeling good you go out to do
something to feel better probably went
beyond capabilities i think and woke up
and didn't know where she was
so she went out kind of sick and thought
she was gonna sweat it out yeah
wow
just went on a run yeah and then
probably and then you know and then just
had no clue
had no clue
like where she i think the good thing is
when she
didn't know where she was she didn't go
anywhere else she stayed put
which
is definitely yeah because you you just
like have no clue where you are you
don't like don't know where to start
going they would have never found her if
it wasn't for you i don't think so wow
i don't know dude she owes you yeah well
now we're married
so i got her back it's like it's a it's
a solid way to win an argument
i think we should i definitely think we
should go here for dinner like no i'm
not really feeling that but remember
that time i saved your life
wow yeah talk about a
bond you guys have a bond for sure
yeah it's a pretty i don't know that's a
crazy bond that's a crazy bond yeah the
fact that you found her